kelsey gabbard has thought a lot about
this of course a former congresswoman
from hawaii currently lieutenant colonel
in the army reserves she joins us
tonight congresswoman thanks so much for
coming on does what's happening in
eastern ukraine whatever you think of it
constitute a core american interest do
you believe
no look at what senator wicker is saying
i want to go back to that for a second
here because
anyone who would propose or even
consider
what he is saying as an option must be
insane a sociopath or a sadist because
let's just understand here so he's
saying let's go and launch a nuclear
attack that would start a war that would
destroy
the american people our country and the
world and oh also the ukrainians so that
we can save ukraine's democracy
i mean it it literally is insane and the
crazy thing tucker is
senator wicker is not an outlier he's
the number two republican on the armed
services committee and you're hearing
the same kind of rhetoric coming from
democrats and republicans in congress in
the administration and in the media who
have no problem with this because they
actually agree with it they're pushing
this same narrative uh themselves and
this is why it is such a dangerous
situation that we are facing as we are
being pushed closer and closer very
quickly as you said to a hot war a
nuclear war that would destroy the world
as we know it
over eastern ukraine i mean the sad
thing is in washington i mean you served
in the congress people like roger wicker
are considered highly informed
intellectuals you know america deserves
better than roger wicker i think it's
fair to say
but
they live in an airless world where they
repeat back to one another both parties
the same stupid talking points do they
know how disconnected from reality this
is
it unfortunately it doesn't appear to be
the case in and this is just points to
uh their their ineptness their their
lack of a capability to really clearly
see what the consequences are of their
rhetoric of what the actions and this
isn't just you know empty words there
are consequences to leaders in our
country influential people in our
country to throwing things out like a
first use
nuclear attack is on the table
this directly undermines our national
security it directly puts the american
people and our country and the world
at risk tucker and it it
what are we trying to accomplish here
because that will be the result that's
so that this is a much longer
conversation but in a minute
why eastern ukraine i mean you can think
of lots of parts of the world that are
critical to our national interests the
shipping lanes in the south china sea
for example or lots of things you could
argue we have to defend this but ukraine
we've been talking about ukraine for
years what is this
the thing that i see here tucker that is
is the same neocons and neolibs in
washington who dragged our country into
regime change wars in places like iraq
and libya and syria the same ones who
are pushing us very quickly into this
war with russia and never stating once
hey what's our objective what are we
trying to accomplish here and how does
it serve our country's national security
interests not a single one of them are
pointing that out
this is not some stone age land in south
asia this is a real country with nuclear
weapons and an actual army like these
exactly
too crazy and by the way they have more
nuclear weapons than we do so thinking
you're just going to launch a nuclear
attack and not see a consequence that
will lead to a nuclear war that destroys
the world is again insane inept and and
i i don't know how many more words we
can use to describe it it's ridiculous
and these people should not be in
positions of power to make these
decisions i couldn't agree more i also
have run out of adjectives
but i agree with the ones you used tulsa
gabriel great to see you tonight thank
you